sooner or later in every man's life
there comes a day when it is not easy a
day when he must chew and this is my day
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking thrones today I want to
dig a little deeper into Maester Aemon
and talk about some of the things he may
or may not have known and what he
planned on doing with this knowledge if
you have not read the books there may be
some very interesting things you do not
know about Maester Aemon and his
relationship with Rhaegar Targaryen and
the three-eyed Raven I know there are
many people out there who only watch the
show and even with the limited
information in the show some of them
believe that maester aemon knew the
truth about Jon Snow and his parents I
know I have wondered this myself because
it always seemed like he may have known
more than he was willing to reveal since
I started reading the books again I've
kept my eyes open for any clues about
how much maester aemon actually know
since this character is now dead we may
never find out but let's discuss this
anyway now when trying to figure this
out we have to think about how maester
aemon could have acquired this knowledge
the truth about jon snow's parentage is
one of the best kept secrets in all of
Westeros there are only a handful of
people that know about this and almost
all of them are dead Rhaegar Targaryen
and Lyanna Stark are dead and everyone
that was guarding the Tower of joy is
dead and even Ned Stark his data Howland
Reed was there and he is presumably
still alive but he hasn't appeared in
this show enough for us to know where he
has been or if he has even talked to
Eamon let alone why would he tell him
that anyway bran stark was shown this in
a vision but by the time bran was shown
this maester aemon was already dead so
how could maester aemon have found this
out well who is the only other person
that has seen Jon Snow's birth the
three-eyed Raven who is also known as
the three-eyed crow or bloodraven his
real name is Brendan rivers and guess
what he's actually related to maester
aemon and Rhaegar Targaryen and
course John Snow the three-eyed Raven is
a bastard Targaryen he's actually made
up of ice and fire just like John Snow
his father was a Targaryen and his
mother was a Blackwood which is a
descendant of the first men some of you
may not know this but the three-eyed
Raven actually joined the Nights Watch
the same exact day maester aemon did in
fact they traveled to the wall together
considering they were related they must
have had a close relationship with each
other Wow at the wall together shortly
after they joined the Nights Watch
the three-eyed Raven actually became the
Lord Commander at Castle black and his
maester was Aemon Targaryen and I'm sure
they gave each other counsel as much as
possible the three-eyed Raven was the
Lord Commander for over 10 years so
these two had to have spent an awful lot
of time together and they must have
formed a strong Alliance together
considering they did have to look out
for each other at the wall like all men
of the Nights Watch should the only
problem is it's not actually known when
the three-eyed Raven started getting his
greenseer abilities but it was well
known that he was into all kinds of
sorcery and the dark arts before he
joined the Nights Watch
so Amon most likely knew he was into
some creepy [ __ ]
but the three-eyed Raven eventually ends
up going missing from Castle black no
one knows where he went or what happened
to him but he may have kept in contact
with maester aemon
now I'm not saying maester aemon knew he
was stuck in the tree the whole time but
the three-eyed raven could have been
sending maester aemon some information
without him even knowing it was coming
from him maester aemon was the one who
took care of the Ravens at Castle black
and there is evidence from the books
that hem said Bloodraven actually
speaking through those Ravens and he
could have spoke with Amon through
dreams just like he did with Bryan it's
kind of interesting that Maester Aemon
and the three-eyed raven both had
something happened to their eyes maester
aemon went blind and bloodraven lost an
eye part of the weirwood tree was
actually growing through his eye socket
I also find it interesting that maester
aemon was able to survive for so long
especially in a place as harsh and cruel
as the wall he was the oldest living man
in Westeros and it makes me wonder if
something or someone was keeping him
alive long enough to serve us
cific purpose he did live long enough to
meet John snow and give him some good
counsel and some of the things maester
aemon said to John snow makes me
question how much he actually knew about
him and the bigger picture most
importantly the survival of the realm
maester aemon was well aware of the
azure Ahai prophecy and he actually
spoke about this with Rhaegar Targaryen
maester aemon and Rhaegar used to
discuss who they thought azor Ahai would
be in Rhaegar told maester aemon that
azor Ahai would be one of his sons you
also have to wonder what made Rhaegar so
obsessed with this prophecy what kind of
insight did he have that led him to
believe that it would have to be his son
who would go on to lead the fight
against the darkness could Rhaegar
Targaryen have had prophetic dreams that
told him this and was it the three-eyed
raven who was manipulating those dreams
you have to keep in mind that all these
characters share the same blood the
blood of the Dragon aiment Rhaegar the
three-eyed raven and john are all
connected through their blood there is
also some evidence of the three-eyed
raven helping john on more than one
occasion one way he was helping him was
through his direwolf ghost in the books
that was actually ghost who found the
dragon glass and the Horn of winter
ghost made John follow him and he leads
him right to where it's buried in who do
you think put that stuff there in the
first place
it also should be noted that there are
only a few characters in this story who
have red eyes and ghosts and Bloodraven
are two of those characters I think
that's just another hint as to who
actually sent the Starks there
direwolves they obviously didn't stumble
across those by accident John also notes
that his eyes look like weirwood eyes
and they belonged to the old gods of the
north also blood Bravin actually helps
John get elected as the Lord Commander
of the Nights Watch and we know that
maester aemon voted for John Snow
himself whenever they vote on who's
going to be the next Lord Commander they
had this big giant kettle that they used
to cast their votes and when they used
it they opened it up and a raven flew
out and it landed right next to John and
it said snow then it said snow a few
more times than
right on Jon's shoulder and everyone
notices it was Lord Commander Mormont's
Raven when that happened along with all
the votes that Jon received it pretty
much sealed the deal for who would be
the new Lord Commander there was no
doubt in my mind that was bloodraven
making the Raven say snow and landing on
Jon's shoulder right when they were
trying to decide who should lead Castle
black there is also evidence that
suggests Bloodraven knows Jon as the
king as well he also uses the Raven and
makes it say King right the Jon Snow's
face and he does this as Jon and Lord
Commander Mormont are talking about
Targaryen Kings this is also not a
coincidence at that time Lord Commander
Mormont is telling Jon about maester
aemon and his family's history and he
tells Jon about all the most recent
Targaryen Kings then he says Jaime
Lannister killed the last Dragon King
but right as he says that the Raven
looks right at John and says King which
indicates Jamie did not kill the last
Dragon King because Mormont is looking
at the last Dragon King as he speaks and
that is Jon Snow in the television show
we know for a fact that Bloodraven knows
about Jon because he shows bran division
but there is more than enough evidence
in the box that shows blood Raven is
keeping his eye on Jon and he is
assisting him whenever he can and it's
no secret that maester aemon favors Jon
Snow he grows very close to Jon almost
immediately and some of the things he
says to John or about Jon make me wonder
what Amon might have known about him or
his purpose even if maester aemon didn't
know Jon was a king he may have known
Bloodraven was keeping an eye on him and
that alone would let Amon know that he
was very important when Stannis and
Melisandre show up at the wall they are
both claiming that Stannis is azor Ahai
reborn and they basically put on a show
Stannis pulls out his sword that
Melisandre named Lightbringer and she
has even done something through this
sword to make it glow maester aemon
might have been blind but he saw right
through their [ __ ] immediately
maester aemon knew that Stannis was not
azor Ahai and he knew that his sword was
not light bringer Amon knows that light
bringer would have had some kind of heat
coming off
of it and Stannis's sword is cold steel
the only reason why is sword would glow
is because Melisandre has done some kind
of magic or spell to make the sword glow
red and orange now in the television
show maester aemon actually dies when
he's at the wall but that's not where he
dies in the books when sam leaves the
wall for Old Town to become a maester he
takes maester aemon with him Jon made
sure that maester aemon got out of there
because he had a good feeling that
Melisandre would burn him because of his
Kings blood unfortunately maester aemon
dies anyway he never actually makes it
the old town but maester aemon does do a
few interesting things before he leaves
before Amon leaves for Old Town he says
one last thing - Jon Snow he gives him
one last piece of advice maester aemon
touches Jon's face and he says you are
half the age that egg was in your own
burden is a crueler one I fear you will
have little joy of your command but I
think you have the strength in you to do
the things that must be done kill the
boy Jon Snow winter is almost upon us
kill the boy and let the man be born
maester aemon gave this same speech to
Aegon Targaryen right as he became king
of the Seven Kingdoms there is a very
interesting parallel here because as we
know Jon Snow is Aegon Targaryen as well
and when maester aemon feels Jon's face
Aegon is the first person he thinks of
the other cool parallel was maester
aemon and Rhaegar both thought that an
Aegon would be azor Ahai reborn they had
the right name but they just had two
wrong
Aegon at the time but there is one other
thing maester aemon does before he
leaves Castle black he leaves a book
behind in Jon's chambers and he tells
him to check out the book because he
marked a specific page he wanted John to
read eventually John does read the
passage that maester aemon left for him
and can you guess what it's about it's
about azor Ahai in his burning sword
Lightbringer
now you could say maester aemon wanted
John to read that so he knew Stannis was
a pretender or maybe maester aemon was
trying to get John to see something in
himself since maester aemon is dead we
will never know
exactly why he left that for John to
read after Amon left that book behind he
heads the old town was Sam and he finds
out about Daenerys and her dragons and
he suddenly thinks he has had the
prophecy wrong the whole time he thinks
he was a fool for thinking that azor
Ahai would be a man because it is now
known that Daenerys was the one who woke
dragons from stone but I think maester
aemon had it right the first time it
seems like it's obviously Daenerys
because she fits the prophecy in a
literal sense but I don't think George
will make it that straightforward too
many people within this story are saying
it's Dany which makes me think it won't
be her because that's what we're led to
believe but the answer will be written
between the lines in a dance with
dragons John does have a dream and he
sees himself standing on top of the wall
and he's armored and black ice with a
burning red sword in his hand
I think this dream will eventually
become a reality after he rises from the
dead and it doesn't just suggest that
John will carry Lightbringer
but it's also another hint at John's
Targaryen blood in the dream he is
armored in black with a red sword which
symbolizes the Targaryen colors now when
trying to decide whether a manu about
john or not is tricky because there are
some hints that point at him knowing and
not knowing maester aemon was on record
saying that Daenerys was the last
Targaryen but you would also have to
wonder if Amon had some kind of
motivation to keep the truth about John
a secret like I said earlier even if a
maan didn't know John was a Targaryen
he might have still had knowledge of his
importance other than just being a good
leader he may have had his own
suspicions that bloodraven was keeping
an eye on him but he may have also known
for a fact because he still could have
been in contact with bloodraven through
dreams or through the Ravens themselves
I think one major motivating factor to
keep this a secret is because of how
this could affect the rest of the story
I'm sure all of you remember the scene
when Bloodraven told brand that the ink
was dry he couldn't change things that
happened in the past well I think a
similar thing could be said for the
present time if a mole knew something
about John he might have had to keep
this a secret so it didn't cause any
kind of
effect in the timeline there is a good
chance that bloodraven knows exactly how
things will play out but in order for
that to happen things need to follow a
specific order events cannot be changed
John cannot find out about his parents
too soon because if he is told too soon
he could do something that causes his
timeline to change one example is John
needed to die at the time that he died
then he needed to be brought back to
life but if someone told John about his
parents before that happened it could
have caused John to leave the wall or do
any number of things differently
therefore he wouldn't have died when he
needed to die and so on and so forth
things need to keep happening in the
exact order they are happening or else
it could cause another event like the
doom of Valyria a ripple effect in this
timeline could mean that the others will
win in life as we know it would end I'm
hoping what I just said made some kind
of sense because I'm not sure how else
to explain that but I think that would
be enough of a reason for maester aemon
to keep his mouth shut if he did in fact
know something about the bigger picture
but let me know what you think I know
there is a lot of different things to
take in and consider but I am wondering
how everyone else feels about this put
all your thoughts and questions and
opinions down below in the comment
section I also just want to mention that
today is actually my birthday so if
everybody wouldn't mind will you please
hit that like button for me one time
I would really appreciate that and thank
you to all of my supporters on patreon
as well have a great day everyone
I will see you in the next one bye
[Music]